I know we're here to talk about
guardians but seeing like next movie is
a big superhero movie how would you
describe the emotions you want to invoke
with a Superman movie I can't say I'm
going to you know I'm looking for any
particular emotions to bring out through
Superman but I don't want it to be
unemotional
um I don't want it to you know deny that
we are as human beings emotional
characters and that Superman is also
that what is going on everybody welcome
back to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have some
very big news about the upcoming
Superman Project for the new DC Universe
under the Helm of James Gunn and Peter
Safran and Superman Legacy which has
been officially announced as the First
new Superman Project coming to the new
universe for DC has all eyes on it right
now especially after everything that
happened with Black Adam and The Rock
bringing back Henry Cavill to play
Superman in the DC EU Henry Cavill was
back a Superman fans were super super
excited for him to be back and then it
was announced that he was actually not
coming back he took it upon himself to
announce it on Instagram and on Twitter
and James Gunn came out and basically
stated that the new Superman that he is
going to have in his new DC Universe is
going to be a younger character and
since then he has announced that he is
going to be writing Superman Legacy and
also directing the film as well so James
Gunn is as close as it gets to this
Superman Project he is leading DC right
now and he's writing and directing the
film and the big question that fans have
been wondering is who exactly is he
going to get to play Clark Kent Superman
well today we have huge news because we
have actual official candidates who will
be test screening for the role extremely
soon less than two weeks actually so
let's dive into this new report and see
who our new Superman could be this is
coming from deadline and Exclusive by
them and they are a very respectable and
major accredited Outlet who give us this
news today they stayed exclusive
following months of going through dozens
of audition tapes Warner brothers and DC
films look to getting closer to finding
the stars of its Superman Legacy movie
as a second round of testing looks to be
imminent so let's talk about this first
part just real quick they've been going
through audition tapes for months now
they've been looking at a lot of
different actors and actresses actually
in fact this article mentions Lois Lane
and the test screens for her as well
we'll get to that but this says they're
going into the second round of in-person
test screenings and that's the big point
they're actually narrowing down who they
want to play Superman and Lois Lane and
they're really really close the article
continues and States insiders close to
the process say the first in-person
tests with Warner Brothers execs and DC
co-heads Peter saffron and James Gunn
who is writing and directing the pick
will take place around Father's Day
weekend or Monday or Tuesday after so
another important thing here this says
that although it's the second testing it
is the first in person testing meaning
the first test was done via audition
tapes so they communicated with who they
liked and asked them to come in and here
are the names of who they asked to come
in who Could Be the future Superman they
say the test screens will take place
around Father's Day weekend or the
Monday or Tuesday after with Nicholas
Holt David cornswed and Tom Brittany
expected to test for Clark Kent aka
Superman they then mentioned the three
actresses for Lois Lane but let's go
ahead and talk about these actors first
right away when you hear all these names
let us know your thoughts about them
down below what do you think could one
of them be a good Superman could they be
a great Superman because honestly that's
what we're looking for and they have
some pretty big shoes to fill or a big
Cape to fill a lot of people really
loved Henry Cavill Superman now right
away no offense to him here whatsoever
but Nicholas Holt I'm having a hard time
picturing it maybe it's just because I
see him as beast from the X-Men films
not sure and he is a great actor I have
nothing against him whatsoever I
actually really like him I just don't
see Superman now that doesn't mean that
he can't bulk up and make his appearance
look like Superman slash Clark Kent but
I just think that David Corin sweat or
Tom Brittany would depending on their
acting skills of course depending on how
they depicted them would make a better
Superman and speaking of David cornswed
I think really has the look of Superman
in fact he really looks like he could
play a younger Henry Cavill and if we
take a look at this fan art right here
by Gustavo friates he looks fantastic as
Superman he really looks the role and
we're going for a young Superman here
according to what James Gunna said and
as far as looks are concerned just
talking about looks right now this feels
like Superman now of course also what is
equally important if not more important
he also does have the acting chops he's
been in a lot including some big TV
shows and movies and he definitely has
what it takes acting wise to play
Superman so does Nicholas Holt I would
add but right now I think David fits the
part more as far as the looks Department
are concerned and then as mentioned we
also have Tom Brittany who I also think
has a good Superman look now I think
David has the most traditional Superman
look but if James Gunn is going down a
route to look a little different than
Henry Cavill Superman or maybe something
that's not so traditional then Tom
Britney might be his choice however I
must say with David Koren sweat the fact
that he does kind of look like a younger
Henry Cavill Superman that would mean
that there is a possibility for a future
Superman to be Henry Cavill perhaps in a
future timeline or Another Universe
where Superman is older and James Gunn
did say that he isn't opposed to working
with Henry Cavill he just wants a
younger Superman for his new universe so
Henry Cavill could show up as Superman
again and if the current Superman actor
kind of resembles him it makes it a lot
easier so right now for me at least
personally Dave and corn sweat would be
my choice but hey let me know what you
think about these three actors down
below who would make the best Superman
to you now moving forward with who they
have coming in for Lois Lane they have
Emma Mackey Rachel bronznahan and Phoebe
dynaver and if I mispronounce some of
those I apologize but right away let me
know what you think of the choices for
these three actresses do any of them
strike a chord with you do any of them
speak to you and go yes this should be
Lois Lane please let us know that in the
comments down below now here if we are
going for a more traditional Lois Lane
comic look I would have to say imamaki
or Rachel Brosnahan probably look more
along the lines of a traditional comic
Lois Lane however I am a fan of Phoebe
dynaver and all that she would have to
do is dye her hair black to fit the role
or maybe even not sometimes she does
kind of have strawberry blonde hair and
the last Lois Lane had red hair so it
could definitely work and I would have
to say that Amy Adams didn't look like a
traditional Lois Lane and they went with
that so any of these actresses I think
would be fine provided that they do an
excellent job with the roll and we know
that James Gunn isn't going to cast
anybody that he doesn't think is perfect
for this role he's already Express
several times that this project means a
lot to him he's very emotionally
attached to this project so it's gonna
be kind of his baby he's gonna put a lot
of care into this and that includes who
he is going to cast to play Clark Kent
aka Superman and Lewis Lane if I had to
pick a personal pairing of who would
look good with each other I would have
to pick David Corn sweat and Phoebe
dynamer and those are my top choices but
I do also think that they actually would
probably look the best together as well
but of course please let us know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below also don't forget to subscribe to
the channel so you don't miss out on any
of the latest DC and Superman news we're
also doing a giveaway giving away a PS5
an Xbox series X some DC items or some
Marvel Legends items the winner gets to
pick one item and we pick a winner at
the end of each month all you have to do
to enter is subscribe and leave a
comment down below also don't forget to
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching wolf
please